[Music]
this is art that you create it's very
unique because it is only visible
under a microscope correct and these are
very accurate sculptures and depictions
that you've done let's give people we'll
start off with just we have some
photographs we'll start with those and
then we'll we'll look at some that are
live this is
nine camels in the eye of a needle that
you sculpted we have here a girl uh next
is a girl with a balloon that is an
eyelash that's a human eyelash no it's
actually smaller than that it's a fiber
off my shirt that was a that's a tiny
fiber and you created that girl with the
balloon you also did you do famous
people this is john lennon
in the eye of a needle
that's correct and you did a famous uh
iconic box match cassius clay versus
sunny list and that's to show you the
scale that's a match head
that uh
and that is how tiny this work of art is
let me ask you a second first question
everybody has is how do you do this how
do you what tools do you use and what
are these things made up the tools are
that they're very sure i have all
different types of tools some of them
are made from broken shards of diamond
which i smash up
so i've got like a little anvil a little
hammer hit it and all the diamonds
little diamond fragments break up into
little splinters yeah and what i do i
saw through all the little splinters and
i use one of them so i got a little
piece of wire drilled a hole in the end
with the finest drill you can get but
the drill wasn't fine enough so i had to
make my own drill and drill a little
hole into the wire then
insert this little piece of diamond it
looks like a little bee sting and what i
do i home i work between my heartbeat i
hold my breath
slow down my my my breathing and then i
use my pulse as a jackhammer
let me understand this please
mr macgyver you slow your heartbeat down
and then you use it you're using
such a fine hand that you the pulse your
actual pulse is creating yeah yeah the
motion that chisels yeah the material
that you're working with sometimes i i
have to work between the heartbeat so
when the heart stops then i move so i
have one and a half seconds to move
between it
um it becomes a nightmare
why why are you doing this
i mean that's the other thing is is it
really do you enjoy doing this no
this is unbelievable to me you don't
enjoy it it's extremely difficult i'll
tell you what it is it's a nightmare
when i start and a dream when i finish
so i have to look at the dream before i
finish okay all right well let's let's
let's move on because i am fascinated i
want to see let's see some uh some
actual uh
samples that you have brought and um
let's look at the first one right now i
think this is in keeping with the theme
today we're having a presidential
election in this country you will put
this under the microscope oh look at
that
there it is that is the head of a pin of
a pin and that is the white house the
white house yeah
and if you look on your right hand side
you'll see the president
what where's the president
why wasn't this impressive enough why
did you then have to put the president
in there
and who can tell why can't you just tell
people all kinds of stuff are in there
why can't you just start saying oh the
four horsemen of the apocalypse are
riding through the dining room
can't you see it well to give you an
idea how small that is that is smaller
than a period stop in a newspaper right
yeah and and and what is it made of the
white it's made of a piece of a
nylon uh tag which is which is like
kevlar stuff yeah it's like a zip tie
that you that you tie um you know bags
with and stuff it's like a very tough
material okay let me ask you a question
because i am looking at the
pin and it just looks like a regular pin
you can't see that there's anything even
on the top of it it's absolutely
incredible that you made this
do you use a microscope when you do it
yeah yeah have to because it's so small
it's just keeping your hands still and
working between the heart beat and
making sure you don't inhale your own
work what do you mean you and
you inhale your work sometimes yes it
does
wait a minute you have spent you you
could spend weeks making a white house
and then suddenly you just have a little
sniffle
and it's in your lungs well
well with this one my antibodies refused
to inhale this one
that's right
you're from across the pond but if it
were parliament you'd accept it
immediately